نتابع التطورات والتفاصيل الاخرى مع
مراسلنا من رفح هشام زقوط هشام صباح الخير
ما الذي بدا به هذا الجمعه من
تطورات الجمعه بدات مع قصف اسرائيلي
متواصل مدينه خانيونس ما زال القصف
الاسرائيلي العنيف عليها مستمر متواصل
القصف في المناطق الجنوبيه الغربيه قبل
قليل نفذت الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
سلسله من الغارات على هذه المناطق تصاعدت
اعمده الدخان من تلك المنطقه وهذه المنطقه
هي منطقه التوغل الاسرائيلي هي منطقه
جامعه الاقصى والمناطق القريبه من
تلك المربع السكني وبالتالي القصف
الاسرائيلي على خانيونس مازال مستمر وربما
هو الاكثر عنفا والاكثر كثافه في قطاع غزه
في ظل استمرار عمليه التوغل الاسرائيلي في
تلك المناطق الجيش الاسرائيلي مازال يحاصر
احياء ومربعات سكنيه باكملها في مدينه
خانيونس يحاصر ايضا مستشفى ناصر وهو
المستشفى الاهم الان في قطاع غزه ويحاصر
ايضا عدد من المنازل في منطقه السطر
الغربي هناك مناشدات من قبل المواطنين
اكثر من 500 مواطن متواجدين في منزل واحد
فقط تواصلوا معي بالامس وهم محاصرون من
قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي لا يستطيعون الخروج
نفذ من عندهم الغذاء والماء ولا يستطيعون
الخروج لان هناك قناصه اسرائيليون يطلقون
النار على المواطنين هناك طائرات مسيره
كواد كابتر تطلق ايضا النار على المواطنين
في تلك المنطقه وبالتالي لا يستطيعون
الخروج ومن بينهم ايضا يعني رجال ونساء
مقعدين ومرضى وكبار في السن ولا يستطيعون
المشي لمسافات طويله الجيش الاسرائيلي
بالامس اجبر النازحين في مركز التدريب
التابع لوكاله غوث وتشغيل اللاجئين الاونر
وهم نازحون بالالاف اجبرهم على الخروج من
المركز والتوجه الى مدينه رفح مشيا على
الاقدام وعند حاجز للجيش الاسرائيلي على
الطريق الغربيه لمدينه خان يونس وعبروا من
خلاله اجبرهم ايضا على ترك الفراش وترك
الامتعه على الارض
وذهبوا الى مدينه رفح مشيا على الاقدام هم
طبعا لم يستطيعوا الوصول الى مدينه رفح
ووصلوا الى منتصف الطريق وهذه طريق مليئه
بالخيام وبالتالي كانوا هناك يعني بلا
ماوى بلا فراش بلا اغطيه بلا اي شيء هم
اطفال نساء ورجال واعتقل عدد من هؤلاء
الرجال وبالتالي الاوضاع صعبه للغايه
باتوا الليله في ظل ظروف معيشيه كارثيه في
ظل احوال جويه سيئه الرياح في تلك المناطق
كانت شديده للغايه لان المنطقه قريبه من
البحر وبالتالي الناس ظلت بلا ماوى هناك
لم تستطع الوصول الى مدينه رفح والحصول
على بعض الاغطيه والفراش من الناس او من
السكان وبالتالي باتوا ليله صعبه وقضوا
ليله صعبه في تلك المناطق الجيش
الاسرائيلي ايضا مستمر في انتهاج هذه
السياسه ويجبر السكان على النزوح بدون اي
نوع من انواع الامتعه او حتى الاغطيه التي
يحاول الحصول عليها من خانيونس واحضارها
الى رفح فرفح مليئه بالسكان ولا يمكن
توفير هذه الامكانات في ظل هذه الظروف وفي
ظل عدم دخول مساعدات تكفي لكل هذه الاعداد
الاعداد النازحين التي وصلت الى رفح من
خانيونس هي اعداد كبيره تزيد عن اكثر من
50,000 نازح و بالتالي هم يحتاجوا الى كل
شيء يحتاجوا الى اغطيه وفراش لان الجيش
الاسرائيلي منعهم من الحصول على هذه
الاغطيه واحضارها معهم وايضا يحتاجون الى
خيام ومنازل او ما يلزم من ماوي وهذه غير
متوفره رفح مليئه بالخيام في كل منطقه على
الارصفه في الشوارع في كل مكان فيه
امكانيه لنصب خيام نصب الناس خياما او حتى
المؤسسات المحليه والدوليه انشات مخيمات
من من الخيام من اجل استيعاب هذه الاعداد
الكبيره مليون و300 ال نسمه وما يزيد عن
ذلك
ايه متواجدين في مدينه رفح بسبب الاوضاع
في كافه مناطق قطاع غزه كافه المناطق نزح
منها الناس بفعل استمرار الحرب
الاسرائيليه واستمرار القصف الاسرائيلي
القصف مستمر على مدينه خانيونس الجيش
الاسرائيلي مازال يحاصر مربعات واحيا
واحياء سكنيه باكملها ما زال يطلق النار
في محيط مستشفى ناصر ويقصف في محيط مستشفى
ناصر سمع عده انفجارات من السكان ومن
الصحفيين والاطباء المتواجدين في مستشفى
ناصر لكن لم يعرفوا ما هي هذه ماهيتها
القصف الاسرائيلي في محيط مستشفى ناصر
وربما مع ساعات الصباح تتكشف بعض الاشياء
التي يمكن رؤيتها بالعين فالقصف
الاسرائيلي وفي ساعات الليل يكون القصف
عنيف وتكون طائرات كواد كابتر تطلق النار
على كل من يتحرك حتى في محيط مستشفى ناصر
انتظر اذا ان ينكشف المزيد لست
معك لاحقا هشام زقوت شكرا جزيلا لك حتى
الان كنت معنا من رفح